pleased to have here the head coach of
notre dame football ranked second in the
college football playoffs
getting set to take on clemson in a
couple of saturdays
for the acc championship brian kelly
fresh off of his third
undefeated regular season as notre dame
football coach how are you sir
good rich how are you doing i'm back you
don't have any of those masks in green
do you
you know what uh i can or special water
i can special order one if you
if you wear it and you and you put it
out there on the old social media you
know
there may be an eye in rich and eisen
but i'm very willing to share because
i know you are i know you thank you hey
uh
when we had you on in the summer and you
were saying basically
uh i don't even have a protocols that i
can tell my my kids parents about just
yet and we're trying to figure out
whether we can play and how we can play
how we can get them here i'm going to
have all these kids under my
uh my purview here and uh when i say to
parents
we've got to have x y and z done i mean
and it was so unknown when we spoke over
the summer if i had told you then
that we would be speaking second week of
december you were 10-0
fresh off of an undefeated season
through your first full
acc campaign as you had to do to play
you just said what to me
i'll take two of those i bet
yeah certainly this has been a a long
road and
and one that certainly there's there was
no blueprint for it
so you know my line has been you know
we've been
we're building the plane as we fly it
and and that's really
you know how we've developed this and in
terms of you know putting the procedures
and protocol in place and certainly
following
you know whatever the national standards
have been because they haven't been
clear at times
but we've got incredible people here at
the university
and uh the medical people have have
guided us along the way and
but as you know rich this is about the
resolve
and the commitment of uh
the student athlete and and how bad they
wanted to play that
that's what's made this work yeah and i
guess
so how do you balance everything knowing
that they also want to be college
students too
you know what i mean well you know it it
that's the question that you have to ask
them and that's what i did before they
even came to campus and said
look guys this is not going to be
anything like you're used to
you're going to have to sacrifice way
more than you've ever sacrificed before
because
the the student life that you know it
will have to change
you know being in large groups going to
parties
um it's it's just not gonna work under
the current condition so
if your priority is to continue to work
towards getting your degree and playing
for a championship
then this is gonna work out if not you
should you should opt out and not play
and so i think the transparency at the
very beginning was
was very important in this process brian
kelly here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about the road ahead here um
and clemson this acc championship game
uh let's just say okay for
uh all intents and purposes that let's
just say um
you don't win this game and i'm just
gonna throw that out there uh do you
still think you deserve to be
in the the final four coach
yeah i mean look i it's not my decision
to make but our body of work is pretty
good i mean
you know we would have beaten the number
one team in the country who knows how
north carolina's gonna finish against uh
miami um 10-1
um probably if if we're making an
assumption
losing to clemson that's number four in
the country
um i think that's pretty good body of
work um
it'll put us right there in terms of you
know making a decision so yeah i would
say that um
you know as long as we're we're
competitive and playing at the
level that we've played at all year yeah
we probably should be one of the four
teams so what
what if you beat clemson and clemson has
two losses and you know obviously how
stout they are you know how good trevor
lawrence is do you think clemson should
should get in you know well then you're
gonna you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to start comparing you
know the two loss teams against the
single loss teams and so
that becomes a whole lot different you
know when you when you're talking about
two losses versus a single loss team so
or an undefeated team like you know with
cincinnati for example so
i think that gets a little bit more
complicated than maybe our situation
that's why
it was so important for us to go
undefeated and which we did and
and now we don't control our own destiny
we still have to win but
it puts us in a better situation what
about a team that's played half the
games you have
you know i i mean how would you feel
that you do go through
this crucible of a season with 11 wins
beating clemson twice two different
quarterbacks for the clemson tigers and
a team that has
almost uh half as many games played as
you do
gets in and you face them what about
that idea well it doesn't really matter
what i believe
it matters what the committee believes
no i mean you're i would call you
i would call you an influencer coach
okay i will tell you what i believe
i believe as a football coach that 10 or
11 games
is a lot different than five or six
games because you're dealing with
injuries you're dealing with the psyche
of a football team
you're dealing with covet for another
five or six weeks
the discipline of your football team
over that period of time
i think it makes a difference and if
you're just saying hey
it's all about the eye test and what
that team looks like in a vacuum
then then it doesn't matter to them
but as a football coach and somebody
that understands
all of the nuances of putting a football
team on
uh the practice field and having to
handle things in the training room and
covid
then i think playing 11 games versus
five or six
absolutely matters brian kelly here on
the rich eisen show and you're a perfect
guy to ask this question to because
again you have played ten games you've
won ten games coastal carolina
is the only other program that is
currently 10-0 as we're sitting here
right
now and so you have gone through
the most abnormal of seasons
with the most what looks like just
looking at a schedule and seeing it the
most
normal looking schedule you can possibly
have right but so
because it is an abnormal season though
the concept of maybe
adding more teams changing the playoff
system the way that major league
baseball did the way that
uh nba and the nhl bubbled up but did
have a different construct and how
people could qualify for the playoffs
what about the idea that maybe if if it
is brought about because of the way
everything is going with the virus
adding more teams would you have an
issue with that as somebody who has
played
as much as you have no i i don't think i
i don't think that ever was really a
concern of mine uh
if if the um if they had decided to
expand the field because of the
uniqueness of the season and some teams
not being able to
um you know play as many games i i was
okay with that
um i think i think what for me
was a bit of a stumbling block is what i
kind of addressed in your question
relative to
you know 10 or 11 games versus you know
five or six games
and but it seems like the committee has
already addressed that
you know and and that's not an issue
with them and that's fine that's their
call that i don't make those decisions i
got to coach the football team but
uh i think that you know from expansion
and if they wanted to do those things i
never really had an issue with that
well i'm just sitting here looking again
at a program like coastal carolina
program like
cincinnati and just seeing how they are
trying their hearts out to get the games
in
and they haven't lost i know and then i
would love to see them i would love to
see them against your team
that should not be penalized uh because
you've lost to clemson late in this you
know what i mean like normally in
regular seasons yeah you lost late sorry
you're out
but this is not a normal season right
and and other teams like ohio state
clearly they want to play michigan this
week but they might not be able to and
we're
we shouldn't hold that against that too
that's why i'm saying maybe just expand
it
you know and let's see what it looks
like with eight teams like right now
dude you you and i have been in this
business a long time yes it's my 31st
year of being a head coach you've been
in it longer
than most and it makes sense to both of
us
but for those guys that make the
decision right it doesn't seem to make
sense to them and i don't know why you
can't even go to the rose bowl and watch
the game and
and we're going to play there why not
expand it and give these other teams in
this unique year an opportunity so
i think you and i are on the same page i
i don't know that everybody else is that
makes these decisions
brian kelly here on the rich eisen show
um is this a one-off
notre dame in the acc i mean uh or or do
you think this
season might lead to uh a relationship
from here on well there is you know that
we've got a relationship with him we're
so thankful that
commissioner swaffer gave us this
opportunity or we would have been in a
very difficult situation right we
would have been trying to put together a
schedule in a similar fashion that maybe
byu had to which was very difficult for
them so
um you know in all of our other sports
as you know are in the acc so
we've had this this relationship with
them
and it certainly will continue um
you know there's no there's no plan to
to to go into
the league full-time but you know
clearly if if we're in the current
situation that we're in next year
um you know we want to be able to
continue this relationship and keep the
options open
so you're in your 11th season there
coach my goodness
right i mean it has been uh i mean
you've been long you've been there
longer than many coaches in the history
of of notre dame football
um i have a plaque they gave me a plaque
at 10 years
is that what you get for 10 years it's
actually sitting on my desk it's a
paperweight
i listen not a lot of people get these
paperweights rich no
uh i would think that's something you
hang on the wall you know i mean
um i could
[Music]
what do you get for 12 years do you get
something for 12 years
i hope i make it to 12. listen i get i
try to get through the year
this is a year to your gig here at notre
dame if you didn't know that oh
come on you're you're you're you're
doing very let's put it this way
you're doing very well you're doing very
well you've got a passionate fan base
including my sound engineer from new
jersey who claims
you claims your school because i guess
what he
couldn't claim rutgers right you didn't
go to you didn't go to notre dame sister
and my nephew went there come on
all right you know i saw montana play
i'm a notre dame fan but you you
knows do you realize though coach do you
know how long newt rockne was there
do you know that i think he was
13 13 yeah 13. yes and so you're
that's the longest 10-year coach you're
you're closing in this is closing
hopefully i can make it oh gosh oh gosh
but
i mean is this is this a would do you
want to stay i mean
and yeah this is this you know for me
you know having
you know seen clearly you know
the development of this program and and
over the years to
to get it to where it is um you know i
want to continue to
you know bring this program um to
the consistency you know of of playing
for championships and and uh
you know be part of the discussion every
year when it comes to college football i
want notre dame to be part of that and i
want to be that guy that can
continues to do that okay well it you
know when you make it to 13
13th year coach okay uh and you get back
on the show
no no no no not at all no here's what
i'll do for you or at least i'll offer
it uh because you know i know you like
breaking trends and setting trends uh i
will personally come to notre dame
and give you a bar mitzvah oh i'll be in
charge of
i'll be in charge of your bar mitzvah
your 13th year when you become
officially a man
um foreign for notre dame i'll do it i
love it
and and i will take you up on that
because i'm assuming there's no one on
campus to do that for you i'll just come
up
am i right now we will probably struggle
there's no depth chart there i don't
think on that front
all right coach take care we'll chat
down the line you guys all right take
care
that's brian kelly everybody what do you
think
you do it at the grotto rich perfect
spot what what are you talking about the
grotto at notre dame very funny i'm
sorry when you talk when you use that
phrase
very very famous place okay very good
the grotto ryan kelly 137 at notre dame
uh five wins shy of new rock knee how
about that
oh go bk i love brian how about that
that's what they thought that's what
they dreamt of when they
changed gears from charlie weiss that's
how long it's
it's been charlie white was his
predecessor eleven years
only lou holtz has a hundred wins but
when you win at notre dame like that
that's when people start you know
sitting there in new york city
and saying hmm maybe when he's coaching
against trevor lawrence in the acc
championship game maybe he wants to
coach trevor lawrence here
not change colors that's that's when the
rumors start
you know you would never change colors
so rich are you a moyle now
is that no that's a breast sir
stick around i'll teach you the ropes
no behind them totally different totally
different situation
but i mean honestly if it's been a long
time since anybody's
had 13 seasons at notre dame newt rockne
is the record holder and
i mean if he is if he makes it to 13 i
will go
to campus you know us where clearly
obviously the pandemic will be behind us
then
knock on wood and uh i will perform um
even though i have no rights to do this
i am jewish i don't get certified online
i can
i can get coached up quickly enough to
deliver whatever needs to be done
can i let a candle on the cake you you
can come and do that yeah i can do that
thank you richard
it's up to brian i mean it's his bar
mitzvah i'm just i'm just i'm i'm just
you know with a couple times you've
letting candle you've laid candles at
bar mitzvahs
rich okay great done it so you've done
it all
you've done it all and he's also wrapped
a police car
around a tree hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here